make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
you know I really wish Matt Fraction
would go back to writing comic books
from Marvel Comics I miss him I think
all he's doing now is writing sex
criminals with his wife Kelly sue
Taconic which admittedly is not a bad
story basically whenever two people have
sex time stops select they go to rob a
bank they sleep together and then like
they freeze time so then they go and
like rob a bank and and leave it's
actually a pretty cool concept they
wrote themselves as the characters but
his his runs a Marvel comics were the
stuff of legend right like like all of
math fractions work in Marvel Comics was
freaking amazing especially Iron Man in
the 8 nightmares light or the five
nightmares that was amazing anyway so
getting into this Odin fighting Galactus
alright this is really really cool this
this basically picks up after the events
of siege right so it's after siege and
after Civil War and so what this means
is an Asgard is in Broxton Oklahoma now
what does that mean
okay so following the events of really
like the events of Ragnarok that that
Asgard itself had essentially been
obliterated when all the forces led by
Loki invaded Asgard and then Thor
essentially fell more or less died or at
least he was supposed to have been dead
until Marvel brought him back and then
you basically went into the aftermath
was his J michael Straczynski 'he's run
and i feel like we should cover that but
it's basically when thor is traveling
around and finding all the Asgardians
and different bodies and so on and we
awakening them and then he recreates
Asgard or at least he recreates s guard
first in Broxton then he goes and finds
everybody but this takes place after
siege right so Asgard being
quote-unquote destroyed by really by
like a lot of people but for the most
part the Sentry being like leveled more
or less and so this is just kind of the
aftermath and that's reason why in the
story you'll see Asgard looking like
it's in shambles and sort of torn up is
because it comes after the events of
siege on Asgard now having said that
since we have this Eve story down in the
description you guys can go check it out
this initially picks up with a guy named
Pastor Mike now I know it seems kind of
weird to start out with a simple pastor
but this guy is actually gonna be really
really important right so pastor Mike is
basically this guy who just it's not
really doom and gloom like you know the
world's ending and like it's all about
the end times all that kind of stuff I
mean it is to a degree he literally says
let's talk about the end of the world
but he's not one of those crazy pastors
right he's just kind of like a pastor
who's there and it's more or less like
hey we've got God's living among us so
this seems to indicate the end times and
so what it does is it jumps to silver
surfer now this is where things get
really really cool because at the moment
Silver Surfer again is still basically
The Herald of Galactus and he will be
for some time the cool thing about this
story is this will actually change that
to a degree
going into infinity and
offenders and New Avengers by Jonathan
Hickman but the idea behind this is that
again Galactus being governed by his
hunger constantly on the need to feed is
basically looking for like a new world
to consume and he's informed by the
solar surfer I have found a new world
like I found a place for you to consume
what I found here is is something that
basically would allow you to feed on it
because the energy is an insane amount
of energy I can sense it from where I'm
at and so what this means like at least
what it does is it switches over to
Asgard in Broxton and you have Thor and
UF's if traveling down into the depths
of the world treat now the world tree in
Marvel Comics is as much abstract as it
is tangible the idea behind the world
tree we've talked about this before the
idea behind the world tree is that this
is basically just a a means by which to
say that the Asgardian mythos write like
all the nine realms are tied into the
world tree itself in the sense that you
basically have Asgard and then you have
like like you like Jotunheim and you've
got Niffleheim and you've got you know
all these different these different
realms to have Nadav lear and all that
and then you've got Midgard earth earth
is tied into it but the issue with like
the creation of all things according to
Asgardian mythos is one of those sort of
situations worse more hearsay and
guesswork because while Marvel does
establish like essentially that Asgard
was a creation of everything I released
as guard created everything what it does
what Marvel also does is at the same
time they'll say but the universe also
came into existence by this form right
so Marvel gives us like different
iterations on how everything came into
existence the Asgardian say one thing
Marvel will depict in a different way
you go when you read like the Eternals
and you listen to the Celestials and
it's like well they created everything
and so it really kind of bounces around
and it fluctuates but inside the world
tree is what's called this well it's
it's just this giant seed right and
we'll learn more about it here in a
second but inside this world tree is
this seed and that's why they why why
Thor and SIF have been sent there to
basically attain this artifact and to
bring it back now this artifact has a
huge amount of power that's tied to it
right like a vast amount of power that's
tied to this thing but Thor's not
initially told what it is by Odin now
for the most part that's that's part and
parcel right the only thing Odin says is
this is a seed right now Odin for the
most part given his hubris and given his
his arrogance about himself doesn't
really see a need to tell for it's just
kind of like you know whatever like Thor
II like he doesn't really need to know
everything he doesn't need to know
everything that I know he something just
needs to be aware that hey like there is
a
I need you to go on and that's basically
it and so switching back to the Silver
Surfer what we end up finding out is
this energy source the Silver Surfer
picked up the one that could basically
signal actus is hunger forever basically
is this seed that Odin had captured
right the seed that Odin had taken from
the world tree and brought back up again
and so it's kind of a cool thing because
one of the other things that I want to
point here point to here is Loki right
now in the aftermath of civil war Marvel
brought Loki back right because he was
just such a popular character really the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I think made
Loki more popular than he had ever been
before but what Marvel did is they
basically de-aged him right they brought
him back as a little kid and he would go
through and live his life as an
Asgardian God going from a child into
his teenage years into his young adult
years and into his adulthood right I
mean that was the intended progression
of his character now one of the things
that came out of Ragnarok that at least
the aftermath to Ragnarok during
Straczynski drown thor is that loki
basically stole the body that was meant
for SIF it's so low-key was walking
around as a chick and he actually wasn't
bad looking what Loki's constantly
trying to do as his younger self is
basically prove his worth and
demonstrate he's not the person he was
when he was older or at least in the
past when he was like the god of
mischief and always causing problems
right it's one of these things where
he's basically desperate to prove his
worth and to show people he can be
trusted and so what it does from here is
it basically switches over directly to
to Odin who's kind of cultivating this
seed and what we ended up learning here
is that this seed is essentially as it
was not really a seed in the traditional
sense that is more of an egg is
essentially a cosmic egg and the idea
behind this is that this egg was
essentially created by eternity before
all things existed right and with this
egg came the creation of the current
universe and so the result was that the
egg was ultimately found by Bohr the
father of Odin who in turn planted the
egg inside of the world tree of Idris
hill and left it there for safekeeping
right now again this is just kind of go
with it if you want to write the idea
that like all things in existence came
into existence because of eternity
creating this cosmic egg and then
basically it it came into existence
whether or at least it continued on when
the universe was born into its current
form you can take it for what it's worth
but you don't really have to believe it
right because it's just one of the
origins of the universe that are out
there at this point in time there's so
many conflicting stories like if you go
when you read Hickman's Avengers the New
Avengers all things that came into
existence were created by the builders
right like after the universe was made
it was the builders who started creating
like planets and life
different things like that so there's a
ton of different origins out there so is
by no means absolute and you don't
really have to find a way to reconcile
it with anything else it's not really
well how does this fit in with all the
other stuff it's just kind of an
ordinary that's out there and you don't
really have to set a whole lot of store
by it but the fact that this seed has
been captured by Odin and it's been
placed inside the destroyer armor this
leaves a Silver Surfer to intervene and
the Silver Surfer literally shows up on
the doorstep of Asgard and says look you
guys have to give me the seed because if
you don't Galactus is coming and
Galactus is going to take it and
Galactus has no problem no qualms with
facing off against all the Asgardians
right I mean your numbers are already
depleted your entire empires and
shambles your powers barely intact like
Odin you do not have much to offer and
in response to this Odin is no you're
not getting it like I'm not giving the
seed to you you know and it's a really
really cool thing right because we've
never really seen an instance when we've
seen like the the Celestials and and
like the Asgardians fighting each other
but we've never seen a tried and true
instance where like you end up having
like a lock just showing up and facing
off against all the Asgardians it's not
something that we've really seen before
but because of the fact that that Silver
Surfer shows up on the doorstep of
Asgard in the aftermath of the fact that
as part was almost totally obliterated
and doesn't really take too kindly to
invaders of sorts this draws the ire of
Thor and Thor literally freaks out and
starts attacking the silver surfer now
Silver Surfer says you have this seed
and this seed has the power to sate the
hunger of Galactus for all time right
until the universe ends like forever and
ever and ever how long that happens to
be this is a vast amount of energy but
the issue at this is that in Odin's eyes
Galactus is not seeking this seed for
the purpose of saving his hunger he's
seeking the seed to attain an extreme
amount of power right to amplify the
power he already has and so that's why
the answer is definitively no and so
what we end up doing is basically
transition to Silver Surfer on the moon
with Galactus sitting there and he says
they said no so like now we got to do
what we got to do and so what this means
is that war is coming to the Asgardians
the forces of Galactus or at least
Galactus himself in the Silver Surfer
are waging war against thee as guardians
and so what you have is is basically all
the forces of Asgard mustered to the
best of their abilities including Odin
as well as Thor's sift the Warriors
three and and like all those guys the
brigade of realms which is basically
like the military force of Asgard all of
them going to war against Galactus and
this is one of the coolest things ever
but what it also does is it switches
over to the
sisters now the weird sisters are an old
concept in Marvel Comics right they go
all the way back to journey into mystery
issue number 102 in March of 1964 and
the way that they're played out in
Marvel is technically they're Olympian
but they hold more sway in Asgard right
it's one of these things where like
whatever it is that the weird sisters do
not even Odin can undo now then the the
basis behind them at least as far as
they function in relation to Asgard is
that they're more of something akin to
like Sears right like they foretell
prophecies and they're like here's how
you can avoid a possible future
different things like that they're very
much holy figures ah but it's one of
those words where Marvel Canada picks
them in a way to where like they're more
powerful than Odin but they're basically
a source by which Odin or Thor or
anybody can go to and say like we're
aware that there's a set of events
coming we're trying to find a way to
avoid it is there anything that we can
do to stop this and that's the reason
why Loki's here Loki's gone to visit the
weird sisters because what they've
basically done a set them on this course
where they say if this fight continues
to go the way that it is then ultimately
your brother's going to die against
Galactus right because your brother does
not have you know Thor does not have the
power to stop Galactus and that's true I
mean he never did for by himself
is no match for Galactus even with his
hammer it's Loki's desire to basically
save everyone except for Odin because
you know Odin will be able to save
himself but the cool thing about this is
that you also have Galactus who
basically uses his power to form these
kind of astral demons more or less you
know these kind of forces that are out
there but where you would normally
expect to Odin and Galactus to
immediately get into a physical
altercation
instead they actually start using their
celebrity and telekinesis a lot of the
physical fighting that takes place at
the outset goes on between like Silver
Surfer Thor SIF and the various you know
astral demons that were conjured by by
Galactus but the the telepathy and the
telepathic battles between the two are
actually pretty awesome because what
ends up happening is Odin goes into the
mind of Galactus and literally goes back
and starts looking in at his past life
and Galactus realizes it right off the
bat right like he realizes exactly
what's going on at that exact moment
right so basically he's experiencing
this memory that he has of the universe
before the current one back when he
originated before that universe ended
and he was born into the new one and
basically is like okay Odin's in my like
this is not right something's wrong here
Odin's in my head right that's that's
what it is now this is a testament to
the power of Galactus right because
usually when you look at a circumstance
where a person with telepathy is using
their powers on someone else
the person who
being exposed to like that telepathy
doesn't usually know what's going on so
what you're talking about here are two
beings with an astronomically high level
of telepathy now and so what you also
end up having here because you basically
have own yeah Odin in his younger years
where he's met by his brothers villian V
and of course as a son of Bor they've
come across a scenario where like their
crops are being consumed by various
insects that are out there right I mean
there's their fields are being are being
you know torn away are being torn up and
the result is that they don't really
have like normal food to eat in order to
survive the winner and so what the one
what we end up learning here is that at
this point in Odin's life they actually
ended up consuming they're dead right
and so it's like like Odin is being
forced to relive these old memories but
so is Galactus and so with this
telepathic battle really kind of coming
to a stalemate right you know in the
sense of like both of them use their
abilities and and really kind of force
the other to relive these memories it
boils down to like the two of them
actually engaging in a conflict now the
problem with this is that Thor jumps in
now
this is the problem here is because the
battle between Galactus and Odin is
supposed to be a battle between the two
of them because their power is so strong
with Odin being able to mess with the
mind of Galactus what this means is that
Galactus has to essentially be in a
steady state right in the sense that
Galactus is trying to use his powers on
Odin when Thor goes flying in and Thor
uses his hammer and Thorin turned like
hits Galactus with it and attacks him
then like Odin immediately gets pissed
because he's just like why would you do
that like literally I could have like
pushed this guy away like we could have
put him in a situation where he
ultimately had a leaf and instead you've
now put us in a situation to where he
could just lose his mind entirely and
attack everyone right it's Thor being
rambunctious being impetuous and not
being patient in the way that Odin is
and so as a result of this you initially
have Silver Surfer that tries to get him
to stand down that tries to get him to
be quiet and tries to get him to say you
have to relax on this and instead like
Thor freaks out and immediately just
starts attacking Silver Surfer and and
it's kind of you know sitting him on the
offense now the problem with this is
that because of that this fight boils
down to a fight between Odin and
Galactus and the crazy thing about this
and it's one of the coolest plays right
you guys have seen this picture a
million times before
but only launches his attack against
Galactus goes flying headfirst and
headbutts him and shatters his entire
helmet right like shatters the entire
like facial structure of the suit he has
the amount of power a person would need
to pull that off is insane right like
it's an astronomical amount of power but
here's where the debate comes in and in
terms of who would win
Odin vs. Galactus and in turn in reality
I would give it to Galactus and the
reason why is because Odin basically
headbutts Galactus and then falls into
the odinsleep and the reason why that
happens the reason why the Odin sleep
ends up happening is because Odin
basically consumes more power than or
assumes it consumes a vast amount of
power right so he's like a battery when
that energy is depleted
you put the battery in the charger
that's what Odin does he goes and
basically takes the Odin asleep which
replenishes his abilities because I was
so extreme because it was such an
extreme level of power that was needed
in order to be able to take out or at
least to headbutt Galactus in that way
and in turn depletes the power of Odin
and he immediately crashes out right so
like it's almost 100 percent of his
power to achieve that Galactus on the
other hand gets up and basically says
Asgardians you bore me right and just
like reassembles his entire suit and
everything so he's basically fun and
this is why I say like it seems as
though Galactus would be able to defeat
Odin right like in a knock-down drag-out
fight Galactus wins because of the fact
like in this particular scenario here
now there are a couple differences here
one of the big differences is that the
odinforce is essentially the life force
of villian V the Brothers of Odin right
so while it is a vast and astronomical
amount of energy it's not unlimited
however what you have with Galactus is
you have the power cosmic an infinite
amount of energy right that's basically
what it is now the price for having the
power cosmic is to always consume life
that exists out there so it's kind of a
yin and yang in his regard but you're
talking about what's essentially an
immensely vast but limited amount of
power in relation to an unlimited amount
of power right so it makes sense the
person where the unlimited amount of
power is going to rent and so as a
result of this where Loki continuing
yoke is continually trying to prove
himself after talking to the to the
fates basically talking to the weird
sisters he ends up stealing the cosmic
egg right that it ends up stealing the
Galactus seed and then leaves with it
now the last bit of information that we
had about that Galactus seemed is that
what it was sitting inside the destroyer
armor and that's incredibly important
because one of the other big things to
come out of this is you end up having
Pastor Mike who much like all the other
members of rocks in Oklahoma are pissed
about everything that's happened now I
kind of saved this to talk about it
right now but with the issues in Broxton
Oklahoma one of the big problems that
they had as Broxton was basically a
peaceful town Riley he was a peaceful
quiet sleepy town that really just sort
of minded this home
business and never really had a lot
going on with things the issue is that
when Asgard was rebuilt suddenly you had
all the Asgardians existing out there
because of the fact that Asgard was
really floating about an inch off the
ground it wasn't really subject to the
to the purview of shield you know
following the events of Civil War and
the superhuman Registration Act and so
what this meant was Asgard could
essentially operate with some measure of
impunity but what this also did is bring
in to events like siege and so when you
have all these villains fighting all
these heroes in Asgard in Broxton
Oklahoma and laying waste to the town
what it's done is it's pissed off the
entirety of the town's denizens right
the entire town citizenry is pissed off
they're like you guys need to leave and
so what ends up happening here this is
probably one of the coolest moments on
the whole story what is up happening
here is Pastor Mike approaches Galactus
right he's like please please please I
beg of you you know have mercy have
mercy on our souls spare our town please
like just leave and the response of
Galactus no it's just like I'm going to
destroy everything and everyone like
they are all going to die your town is
going to die you are going to die the
Asgardians are going to die and as your
art is going to be obliterated that's
just the way it is I'm getting that go
like to seed come hell or high water
that's just the way it goes
and so it's it's cool here because
because in response to this of course
you end up having to destroy your armor
which is basically summoned uh and that
the other destroy your armor in turn
takes it takes Thor's hammer and it's
kind of crazy because millinery actually
leaves Thor right like in abandons Thor
and immediately takes over to the you
know takes off to the destroy your armor
now this is kind of an important thing
because this is one of the things that
was built on by Jason Aaron right the
idea that mule Nura has a mind of its
own that it can it can function
according to its own will if Thor uses
it it's because they hammer allows Thor
to use it it's just this is really kind
of building up and it's really
snowballing and leaving in adjacent
Aaron's run where it's like the hammer
can do whatever it wants to it can it
can it can basically be its own person
and so the result of this is that with
Galactus basically being aware or at
least his last understanding was that
the Galactus II was housed with India
within the destroyer armor when the
destroyer shows up with the power of the
Galactus seed wheeling Thor's hammer
basically what this means is that
Galactus would be totally obliterated
right so ultimately he ends up leaving
now the other reason why he leaves is
because of the fact that where he
attempts to go and destroy the destroyer
armor and know
he may be in there the results of the
Silver Surfer says no the seat is gone
the seed was taken out of the destroy
your armor we don't know where it is now
but it's basically gone here and so what
this means is a Galactus basically ends
up retreating now the reason why the
seed is gone is because Loki took it and
this is where the prophecy of The Weird
Sisters comes into play right the
prophecy being that Loki has to act to
remove the seed from the from the
destroyer armor and then take it to
someplace where he can never be reached
essentially all the way inside the
depths of Idris so all the way back it
is very very bottom a point where nobody
can really reach it worse is kind of
lost in this sort of massive pool of
what's essentially just time and space
and so as a result of that Galactus ends
up basically standing down and Galactus
walks away but this is again the the
significance of Loki because had Loki
not done that and had the seed been left
inside the destroyer armor Galactus
could have destroyed it
right because with the destroyer armor
one of the things that was established
back in the day when it came to Thor is
that the destroyer armor is not
indestructible it can be obliterated the
the Celestials wiped out the destroyer
right I mean you the destroyer armor was
created in relation to the Celestials
returning for the second or third house
I think it was and in the the destroyer
armor was made by the sky fathers by
Odin and the sky fathers in order to
basically defeat the Celestials and the
Celestials obliterated it like that they
were just like done and so it's kind of
a cool thing because what ends up
happening is with Galactus leaving
knowing they do be foolish for him to
continue a war with the Asgardians
because he you know ultimately it's his
hunger would get the better of him right
like when all the power he has and while
the power is essentially limitless he
has to consume the energy of
life-sustaining planets in order to
maintain access to that power for lack
of a better word what this means is that
if he were to continue this war with the
Asgardians he would inevitably lose
eventually because of the fact that it
would just be a war of attrition and he
would tire out and ultimately he would
end up falling and so for his own
self-preservation he ends up leaving
Silver Surfer goes to find a new world
form and that's basically the end of
that but what this does is it leads to a
couple different things the first is
that Silver Surfer basically shows up
and he grabs Pastor Mike right and says
I noticed that you you essentially
looked to Galactus and that you
confronted him neo and having no idea
what it was that you were facing having
no idea that you could have been
obliterated in the blink of an eye like
you could have just been phased and just
removed from the from all existence
right as if you if you never were but in
the face of what was essentially
absolute destruction you still
confronted them anyway there's heroism
in that and so rowdy pastor Mike and
then showing up to
to asgard alongside Galactus what is up
happening as a silver server says okay
fine we can find a truce here the
Galactus seed is currently hidden away
like it's currently removed away I don't
know where it is it's outside the view
of myself and Galactus as long as it
stays there we have no quarrel with you
but if you go and you find the Galactus
seed and you bring it back we will
return and the world will continue and
ultimately it's an acceptable in an
acceptable sane of circumstances the
problem with this is that there'd be no
way for them to know if Odin attain the
Galactus seed again so as a result you
end up having Silver Surfer who stays on
earth the problem with this is that
Galactus needs a hero and so Pastor Mike
becomes a new Herald for Galactus and in
turn Silver Surfer stays confined to
earth now there's a couple reasons why
this was done right with Pastor Mike
becoming prey toward the new Herald of
Galactus Silver Surfer returning to
earth and being locked there was a way
from novel to kind of return him back to
his roots right because that's really
where Silver Surfer gained the most
prominence he originally appeared in the
Fantastic Four in the Galactus trilogy
and then following that Marvel launched
an ongoing series with his character
where he was basically learning about
earthlings and what it meant to be a
superhero
on earth it proved to be exceedingly
popular people loved it model changed
that and then his stories were kind of
hit and miss for the next few decades or
so and so really you know going forward
by what I would say is probably 20 years
20 25 30 30 years Marvel jumps forward
and they say okay let's confine him back
to earth again and let's see how this
goes the problem with that is stories
weren't all that great but it was cool
to see it was interesting for what it
was but that's basically where it ends
that's basically the story of Odin
finding Galactus but without being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain to make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]